here i told ted i put up halloween
decorations yesterday here he nearly
tackled me yeah he's like don't do it
again these were pumpkins they're heavy
okay
pumpkins are approved if you were
stringing lights you need to restring
them yeah otherwise they're actually in
your neighbor's yard now strung up on
your neighbor's yards tree i actually
have a uh a viewer comment here a
question from tammy belt who's asking me
on twitter is it safe to put trash cans
out overnight for morning pickup
no tomorrow do it tomorrow get up early
get up that's exactly it yeah get up
early do that tomorrow you put them out
and again they'll be in my yard i know
it stop the alarm tammy set the alarm
for sure
no don't get me wrong it's still going
to be windy tomorrow morning good day
we'll cover that but the strongest winds
are tonight all right so i wait till
tomorrow a live look outside look at
this just you can't even see the las
vegas strip this is all dust outside
right now here's our storm reporter
right with these strong winds outages
downed trees road debris all possible
still
gusts could peak up to 60 miles per hour
in some neighborhoods hence the wind
warning mountain snow yeah we talked
about this now here are your totals
between one to four inches of new fresh
snow and lee and kyle canyon
by tomorrow great to see that it's
october 70 in centennial hill 63 in
december 72 for downtown 72 green valley
same for henderson 70 for roads ranch
mountains edge 68 for seven hills once
that cold front passes through these
numbers are going to drop big time and
you're going to need the jacket for
tonight 73 boulder city 59 already for
you and prompt and 57 for sandy valley
84 still in laflin you have not seen
that cold front yet valley radar showing
some echoes here right so this looks
like rain is coming down when really a
lot of this is dust right now for the
las vegas valley
echoing back on our radar this however
out here is showers and rainfall that's
moving south of mount charleston and
that is changing over the snow on mount
charleston right now when you see those
blue and white colors that's actual snow
here's the low that's responsible for
all this wind that's going to dive down
this is more inland so it's carrying
rain with it but not a lot if it was
more out the sea then they could pull up
some of the moisture but it's more
inland so look at this shower chances
rain chances go up big time as you get
through the evening so we're going to
see some rain in parts of the the region
and then it decreases a little more
after midnight and then tomorrow
unfortunately we're not going to see any
of that precip at all as we clear up
your wind forecast they will peak again
early evening and then decrease more
overnight but still remain elevated
around 45 mile-per-hour gusts tomorrow
morning 52 overnight very windy and
chilly a chance of showers maybe even a
rain-snow mix 65 for tomorrow windy and
much cooler with areas of dust all right
here's your eight day forecast we have a
cold start to our morning after tomorrow
wednesday thursday and friday your
morning start in the low 50s to high 40s
wednesday morning warmer though for the
weekend that's your most accurate
forecast back to you